[Musique]
m
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre cet
après-midi les travaux des sénateurs et
le sénat qui continue sa commission d'
enquête sur la gestion de la crise du
coroner virus et sur l'évaluation des
politiques publiques pour faire face aux
pandémies
ils entendent cet après midi la
directrice de l'offre de soins au sein
du ministère de la santé katia julienne
je vous laisse écouter cette audition la
stratégie savoir si elle n'a pas été
dictée notamment par les capacités
disponibles tout au moins dans un
premier temps et je vais vous demander
de présenter une intervention
préliminaire d'environ 10 15 minutes
vous êtes la seule intervenante au conte
on sera un peu plus large sur le le
timing 10 15 minutes et ensuite je passe
la pole pour rapporteur trois
rapporteurs
et puis nos collègues qui souhaitent
également posé des questions au
préalable commission denquête donc je
vais vous demander de me prêter serment
sachant que tout est mia jeu mensonge
est il soumis à une peine de prison
pouvant aller jusque 5 ans et une amende
pour être l'hôte jusque 75000 euros
donc je vais vous demander madame la
directrice katia julienne de prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité de lever la main droite et de
dire je le jure je jure ceci est en fait
je vous rappelle que le port du masque
est bien sûr obligatoire je vous
remercie d'être vigilants par rapport à
ça même quand on s'exprime et sans plus
tarder je vous donne donc la parole
madame la directrice
merci monsieur le président alors
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames
pardon
les excuses bien sûr du président milon
le président de la commission des
affaires sociales qui a retenu sur son
département et c'est la raison pour
laquelle en tant que vice président
j'anime cette réunion merci même très
bien merci mesdames les sénatrices et et
messieurs les sénateurs
tout d'abord en introduction de mes
propos préliminaires je voudrais
commencer par saluer bien sûr
l'engagement des soignants et plus
largement de l'ensemble des personnels
qui ont concouru au bon fonctionnement
du système de santé
c'est important de le dire devant vous
et je dois souligner les efforts et
l'engagement qui ont été les leurs
pendant toute la gestion de la crise de
l'épidémie et encore aujourd'hui je
voudrais aussi souligner l'importance
qu'a revêtue pour nous l'ensemble des
relations que nous avons pu avoir et
nouée pendant la crise avec les
fédérations hospitalières que vous avez
auditionné ce matin les conférences
hospitalière les sociétés savantes mais
aussi france aso c'est important de le
dire puisque pour nous ces contacts ont
été permanents pendant toute la gestion
de l'épidémie et c'était très important
de les avoir et je pourrai revenir dans
la façon dont nous avons pris des
décisions et gérer avec eux les
situations qui qui ce que auquel nous
étions confrontés rapidement je voulais
peut-être souligné trois points devant
vous le premier quant au rôle de la
direction générale de l'offre de soins
pendant l'ensemble de la crise nous
avons mis au service de la direction
générale de santé de la santé qui comme
vous le savez dirige la crise sanitaire
non seulement notre capacité à activer
l'offre de soins mais aussi une partie
de nos agents qui seront rejoints les
cellules que la dgs a mis en place
cellule logistique c'est le l'opération
par exemple ce qui a permis une agilité
au niveau national agilité que nous
avons retrouvé dans les ars et dans les
établissements santé je tiens à le
souligner parce que c'est quelque chose
qui auquel nous ne sommes pas habitués
mais nous avons profondément fait
évoluer nos organisations internes pour
faire face aux contraintes et aux
difficultés de la gestion de l'épidémie
ça a été vrai aussi en interministériel
et j'y reviendrai puisqu'un certain
nombre d'évolutions ont pu être prises
avec des décisions rapides je pense
notamment à la garde des enfants des
soignants qui a été extrêmement
importante pour garantir la continuité
des soins ou encore à la prise en charge
des transports notamment les
taxi pour ramener les soignants à leur
domicile après leur activité sont deux
exemples qui manifeste la très forte
coopération interministérielle pendant
l'ensemble de la gestion de la crise
c'était le premier point que je voulais
souligner si je devais résumer
finalement les deux lignes directrices
qui ont été les nôtres pendant
l'ensemble de la gestion de l'épidémie
ça a été d'une part le soin que nous
avons mis à essayait constamment de
lever les freins et de faciliter
l'adaptation du système de santé pour
aider les acteurs qui étaient eux sur le
terrain
j'en donne quelques exemples la
déprogrammation bien sûr mais aussi par
exemple les autorisations
exceptionnelles
nous avons permis aux ars de les
octroyer dans des délais beaucoup plus
court que ce que nous faisons
traditionnellement ce qui a facilité
l'extension d'activités notamment de
réanimation je donne un autre exemple
l'appui sanitaires aux ehpad qui a été
un levier extrêmement important pour
faciliter la prise en charge sanitaire
des résidents en ehpad que nous avons
fait évoluer dans des délais extrêmement
courts
autre fil conducteur faciliter
l'accompagnement de ces évolutions avec
des mesures concernant les ressources
humaines pour faciliter sur un plan
administratif et juridique mais aussi
financier
la réaffectation et les renforts des
professionnels de santé dont entre les
établissements phénomène qui a été assez
massive comme vous le savez c'est aussi
le cas pour la garde des enfants ou les
taxis par exemple que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure
j'y tiens beaucoup parce que finalement
ça a été une posture très importante
puisque en à une station centrale comme
vous le savez nous ne sommes pas en
première ligne mais nous devons
accompagner les acteurs c'est-à-dire
faciliter les évolutions et sommes j'en
oublie une qui était très importante et
qui a d'ailleurs été évoquée ce matin
c'est la garantie financière c'est à
dire que nous avons assuré tout de suite
aux établissements de santé qu'ils
soient publics et privés qu'ils auraient
un maintien de leurs financements que ce
soit des aides en trésorerie des
délégations financières et ensuite la
garantie de financement pour qu'il n'ait
pas de préoccupations financières et
qu'il se concentre sur la gestion des
patients coville voilà quelques exemples
et je pourrai revenir mais qui sont
importants dans ce que à notre sens ce
doit être la posture d'une
administration centrale en appui des
acteurs de terrain
la deuxième chose que je voulais
souligner qui est importante aussi
c'est qu'ensuite après cette période de
gestion de l'épidémie heures et
lesquels je donne des points saillants
sur lesquels nous pourrons revenir bien
sûr nous avons eu à coeur d'organiser
dans des délais extrêmement courts avec
un certain nombre d'acteurs d'acteurs
des réunions pour capitaliser ensemble
sur ce qui s'était passé et sur les
enseignements que nous pourrions en
tirer ensemble nous l'avons fait avec la
communauté des urgences hospitalières
lors d'une réunion de la céni h dédié à
cette question qui s'est tenu fin juin
nous l'avons fait également avec un
certain nombre de sociétés savantes bien
sûr avec les réanimateurs nous l'avons
fait aussi avec les mpr et c'était
intéressant parce que je vous donne un
exemple les mêmes terres les médecine la
médecine de prévention gré de
réadaptation pour les nécessaires en
fait c'était important parce que ils
nous ont donné un exemple d'une avancée
que personnellement je n'avais pas enfin
dont j'avais sous-estimé sans doute
l'importance c'était toute l'activité de
télésoins des kinés qui a permis d'en
laisser sert de poursuivre la prise en
charge de patients y compris non
qu'ovide y compris pendant la période de
confinement et j'avoue que je pensais
davantage à la télémédecine pour les
médecins généralistes pour les
infirmiers est patent pour les kinés
donc je le souligne parce que ces
échanges ont été importants pour nous
dans les enseignements que nous pouvons
tirer de ces de ce que nous avons appris
finalement de la gestion de cette
épidémie à la fois avec deux objectifs
se préparer à une évolution un éventuel
rebond ou à une reprise de l'épidémie
d'une part et puis aussi en tirer des
enseignements pour des évolutions plus
pérenne sur le fonctionnement notre
système de santé
nous avons eu bien sûr des échanges avec
les deux cnp de réanimateurs que nous
avons tenu en juillet et que nous
continuons en septembre puisque nous
devons travailler avec eux alors à la
fois pour eux nous préparer sur la
reprise de l'épidémie nous avons
retravaillé avec eux des instructions
que nous avait renvoyé dès la fin du
mois de juillet aux ars pour qu'ils se
tiennent prêts en cas de reprise de
l'épidémie et d'autre part et ça ce sont
des discussions qui se poursuivent avec
eux sur des évolutions plus structurelle
des services de réanimation à la fois
sur les professionnels je pense
notamment aux infirmiers mais aussi sur
la question du capacitaire qu'une
question importante qui l'ont soulevé à
juste titre et sur laquelle nous devons
travailler avec eux pour déterminer
quels sont les bons critères de
détermination des capacités de
réanimation que ce soit au plan national
mais surtout
au plan régional puisque ces capacités
sont diverses dans les différentes
régions donc ça c'est un sujet important
que nous ne réglerons pas dans les deux
mois qui viennent mais qu'il faut
impérativement que nous traitons nous
devons travailler à la fois sur une
temporalité courte mais aussi sur une
temporalité de moyen terme
et enfin bien sûr sont intervenus les
décisions du ségur qui sont un élément
important d'une part avec des décision
qui était très attendue par l'ensemble
du système de santé je pense à des
décisions concernant l'investissement
hospitalier ou revalorisation des
carrières des professionnels à la
révolution rémunération au prix mais
aussi au parcours de carrière de
l'ensemble des professionnels qu'ils
soient personnels médicaux et non
médicaux c'était important
ces décisions ont été prises on parle là
de plusieurs milliards et maintenant
nous allons les mettre en oeuvre et nous
les mettons en oeuvre dès maintenant
donc ça c'est un volet aussi important
avec d'autres sujets qui sont importants
à la fois pour notre système de santé de
manière pérenne mais aussi dans
l'hypothèse d'un rebond
je pense à l'eau maintien de la
téléconsultation à 100%
nous voyons que l'épidémie a permis
d'accroître très notablement le nombre
d'actes de télémédecine de télé de soins
avec des professionnels assez différent
la télémédecine a je pense trouver sa
place nous devons la conforter de
manière pérenne c'est très important et
donc comme vous l'avez vu nous avons
maintenu la prise en charge à 100% des
téléconsultations je pense également à
ce que nous appelons l'ancrage sanitaire
autour des ehpad pendant la gestion de
l'épidémie nous avons demandé aux ars de
mettre en place un maillage sanitaire
autour des ehpad des astreintes
bien sûr pour qu'aucun epad ne sache pas
qui appeler pour avoir un appui
sanitaire et ça à la fois pour les soins
palliatifs mais de manière plus générale
pour un appui aux professionnels dans
les ehpad
nous avons demandé aux équipes mobiles
de gériatrie de sortir de plus en plus
de l'hôpital pour aller vers les ehpad
et les aider nous avons levé les
restrictions qui pouvait limiter les
interventions de l'hospitalisation à
domicile qui a conduit un travail
remarquable auprès des résidents en
ehpad pas exclusivement mais beaucoup
voilà quelques exemples des d'évolutions
importantes qui nous paraît essentiel de
pérenniser pour maintenir ce dispositif
pour les éventuels l'éventuel rebond qui
pourrait intervenir deux
on nous met de manière pérenne pour
ancrer sanitairement la prise en charge
des résidents en ehpad et enfin dernier
exemple je pense au déploiement du
service d'accès aux soins qui nous
permettra de parfaire l'organisation de
la régulation médicale avec les
généralistes les ouïes les généralistes
d'une part et les urgentistes d'autre
part c'est quelque chose que nous
déployons nous avons demandé aux ars qui
ont monté des projets de site pilote de
les déployer ne nous en faire un retour
pour le 30 septembre
voilà un troisième exemple de dévolution
structurelles qui peuvent être pour
certaines très rapide pour d'autres qui
peuvent prendre quelques mois mais que
nous devons enclenché dès maintenant
pour améliorer notre système de santé de
manière pérenne et à la fois nous
préparer aux évolutions qui sont devant
nous il reste encore d'autres travaux à
accomplir je parlais des autorisations
pour les soins critiques et de la
question du niveau du capacitaire mais
je pense à d'autres sujets comme l'un
d'entre eux qui a été évoquée ce matin
celui des autorisations exceptionnelles
nous l'avons mis en place dans le cadre
de l'état d'urgence donc pour une durée
limitée et nous nous interrogerons en ce
moment pour savoir si ce ne serait pas
intéressant et je pense à titre
personnel que ça le serait de confier
cette responsabilité directement aux ars
plutôt qu'aux administrations centrales
pour leur permettre de décider
directement de l'octroi de ces deux
autorisations dans un délai plus court
ce qui leur permettrait d'avoir une
souplesse adaptée en fonction de la
situation dans leur région
voilà le dernier point que je souhaitais
évoquer et enfin peut-être pour pour
conclure cette introduction et vous
laisser me poser les questions que vous
le souhaitez je tenais à évoquer un
dernier sujet il me semble si je devais
tirer un enseignement assez général
finalement de ce qu'a pu être le rôle de
la direction générale de l'offre de
soins
c'était que pour nous il était important
d'avoir des échanges permanents avec les
acteurs de terrain pour identifier le
plus tôt possible les difficultés qu'ils
étaient de notre ressort et modifier
dans les délais les plus courts
possibles les textes qui étaient des
freins administratifs ou les leviers
financiers que nous devions faire
évoluer pour leur permettre de faciliter
leurs actions au plan local
c'est très important parce que c'est
vraiment l'état d'esprit qui nous a
animés pendant les quelques mois de
cette crise et je crois que c'est très
important de préserver cette écoute
entre nous et cette capacité de
réactivité qui nous conduit aussi
à déterminer des cadres généraux mais
aussi à laisser les ars avec les acteurs
de terrain déterminer les modalités
concrètes d'application
je vous donne un exemple lorsque nous
avons demandé aux ars de reprendre les
soins y compris orco vide tout début mai
de mémoire je crois que c'était le 7 ou
le 8 mai nous avons indiqué qu'elle
devait le faire en fonction de la
situation de leur territoire tout début
mais la situation n'était pas
équivalente en engrais en test ou en
occitanie pour ne citer que deux
exemples
il appartenait donc au plan local de
déterminer en fonction de ses
contraintes et de ses capacités
comment la reprise d'activité pouvait se
faire ça n'était pas l'administration
essentielle 30 râle de donner des gars
de l'un sous des textes très prédictif
sur les modalités de reprise de cette
activité
voilà ce que je souhaitais vous dire
mesdames et messieurs l'introduction et
je suis bien sûr à votre disposition
pour répondre à vos questions
merci m la directrice mais vous nous
avez dressé un tableau de ce que vous
avez fait nous n'en doutons pas que vous
avez essayé de faire au mieux mais il ya
des choses qui ne sont pas trop bien
passé ce que vous pourriez nous citer
des des problèmes qui est on était sur
le terrain comme la réorientation la
pénurie de matériel
les malades non-atteinte qu'ovide qui
ont connu des retards de soins est ce
qu'il ya deux trois points que vous
souhaitiez mettre en exergue avant les
questions je ne permets de donneurs à
porter parce que dans les auditions que
nous avons eues on constate qu'il ya eu
un certain nombre de dysfonctionnements
qu'on ne critique pas victimes d'une
crise mais qu'on peut peut-être
améliorer ce que vous notez 2,3 points
en préambule qui ne contraint 10 noeuds
contre a dit pas ne sont pas en
contradiction avec vos propos mais que
vous pourriez parfois dont vous pourriez
parfois tirés conséquences pour l'avenir
très rapidement avant de passer la
parole au rapporteur
oui j'en ai un monsieur le président est
qui qui nous qui concordant avec ce que
je viens de dire sur la question de
finalement de la déclinaison entre
les décisions nationales et les
décisions régionales c'est vrai que au
moment de la montée de l'épidémie
nous ne savions pas à l'époque si
l'épidémie allait concerner ce qui était
le cas la faim etc essentielle ment
quatre régions ou si elle allait se
propager sur l'ensemble du territoire
nous avons donc pris des décisions avec
un usage très fort je pense à des
programmations
sur l'ensemble du territoire pour
dégager des capacités à la fois en
matériel en renfort en personnel et
aussi de prise en charge de patients si
l'épidémie avait atteint la même le même
niveau dans les régions pour lesquelles
elle ne l'a fort heureusement pas
atteint c'est vrai qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui nous devons recourir à ces
outils à ces leviers qui sont des
leviers utile mais de façon beaucoup
plus proportionnés et localisés c'est à
dire que je pense que la déprogrammation
reste intéressante mais elle doit être
maniée avec beaucoup de précaution et je
pense que nous y reviendrons parce
qu'elle a des conséquences en fonction
de la situation dans une région voire
dans un département et être beaucoup
plus circonscrite finalement à
l'épidémie et vous l'avez vu nous avons
développé un certain nombre
d'indicateurs qui nous permettent de
prendre des mesures beaucoup plus limité
dans l'espace et dans le temps en
fonction de la situation et de son
évolution
ça pour moi c'est un ancien élément très
important vous avez raison de le dire et
c'est quelque chose que nous ne savions
pas au moment où l'épidémie était en
progrès sur moi je crois que là c'est
quelque chose de majeur y compris alors
une conséquence de ce que je viens de
dire
nous avons concentré les évacuations
sanitaires pour les patients qu'aux vide
peut-être que demain nous serions
conduit à les y recourir pour d'autres
types de patients pour piloter les
places disponibles
c'est possible je ne sais pas si ce sera
le cas mais en tout cas c'est possible
donc je crois que nous avons développé
le bon outil mais nous devons maintenant
en avoir un usage plus proportionnés
dans l'espace et dans le temps si je
puis dire merci je passe la thèse parole
à bernard jomier bernard ensuite sylvie
et puis catherine conclure
merci monsieur le président d'abord
effectivement moi je fais quand même
suite à le président nous a retiré les
mots de la bouche et il sait très bien
ce qu'on pense donc il était tout à fait
en capacité de le faire mais on aimerait
vous entendre sur justement qu'est-ce
qui qu'est ce qui pour vous on appâte
fonctionner de façon optimale et
évidemment sans les voies d'amélioration
en matière d'offre de soins je prends un
exemple actuel
on est dans une phase de l'épidémie où
la question du dépistage est au coeur de
notre capacité enfin il est un des
éléments en tout cas important de notre
capacité à freiner la circulation du
virus et on voit bien qu'on est
confronté à une situation où cette offre
est difficile à mettre en oeuvre à la
fois de façon technique dans les lieux
donc on est en train de de déborder on
va dire les laboratoires qui sont les
lieux principaux de réalisation du
dépistage et on voit les initiatives qui
sont prises par les collectivités
locales par les agences régionales de
santé parlait sais pas mais tu sais à
part des différents acteurs du système
de soins pour porter une offre de
dépistage en dehors des laboratoires
pour élargir et puis en même temps dans
la détermination du public cible de
cette offre de dépistage ou je prends
cet exemple parce que on fait face à une
épidémie qui sans arrêt nécessite qu'on
s'adapte dans notre réponse aux
caractéristiques à ce qui se passe avec
la jsk votre sens notre système de santé
et dans sa conception adaptée est pensé
pour la gestion d'une épidémie et quelle
quelle quelle voie d'amélioration
verriez-vous pour améliorer cette cette
réponse
et puis j'ai deux deux questions en
particulier
premièrement l'offre de soins en ehpad
non pas ce qui a été fait vous nous
l'avez dit la réaction que kelly la dg
os de de faciliter et d'améliorer
rapidement une fois que l'épidémie est
survenu love 200 et palmer comment
évoluer cette offre de soins c'est les
ratios notamment entre 2003 et début
2000 20 hier avant la période épidémique
sur l'offre de soins on n'est pas des
dans les établissements médico sociaux
alors vous aurez peut-être du mal à nous
apporter une réponse complète oralement
mais on aimerait avoir des éléments et
puis vous pourrez évidemment complété
par écrit et deuxièmement la question
s'est posée et se pose 2 pourquoi le
secteur ambulatoire a été aussi peu
mobilisé il était prévu d'ailleurs en
mars un moment une répartition plutôt
bon bah les formes légères dans en
ambulatoire les formes plus un hôpital
ça n'a pas vraiment bien fonctionné mais
on pourrait dire aussi en amont puisque
les alertes à la crise sont survenus
beaucoup plus précocément on a vu que
c'était courant janvier que les
premières alertes avaient été un peu
actionné pourquoi est ce que le secteur
angry le soin ambulatoire n'a pas été
mobilisés de façon satisfaisante
pourquoi il n'a pas été pleinement
participants à l'offre de soins est la
lutte contre l'épidémie dans cette
première phase
voilà je remercie la directrice vous
répondra aux questions chacun d'eux
n'aura à porter ou non notre union
jusque 16h environ donc on a le temps de
nous parler mais il faut quand même si
oui vous pour revenir à votre question
de fond qui est finalement est ce que
l'organisation de notre système de soins
est adapté pour gérer une épidémie et
vous donner des exemples je vais en
reprendre deux que je partage nous avons
insuffisamment pendant je pense trop
longtemps
tisser des liens entre le secteur
médico-social et le sanitaire
c'est une constatation et nous avons
demandé finalement aux ars en quelques
jours de monter des dispositifs qui
viennent facilité pour tous les ehpad en
tout cas c'était notre demande
cette facilitation de la prise en charge
et j'ai envie de dire quelles que soient
les acteurs sanitaire hôpitaux de
proximité nécessaires
achat des équipes mobiles de gériatrie
et là je pense que nous avions une
faiblesse dans l'organisation de notre
système de santé que nous devons
impérativement consolider et pérenniser
c'est très important que nous fassions
en sorte qu' il n'y ait plus un ehpad
sans appui sanitaire et je pense que là
ça a été un enseignement très fort sur
lequel nous devons absolument avancer
ensuite le deuxième point comme vous le
disiez et vous relisez les
recommandations de début mars sur la
place de la ville comme vous l'indiquez
acquis nous donnions effectivement la
mission de prendre en charge les
patients avec les pathologies les plus
modérés c'est vrai que probablement le
rôle a été insuffisant et nous devons
nous interroger sur la façon de
renforcer la place de ses acteurs
maintenant je le module un peu puisque
je regardais les chiffres des activités
notamment des médecins généralistes
c'est vrai que le nombre de
consultations dans les cabinets a
beaucoup baissé beaucoup baissé mais en
revanche le nombre de téléconsultation à
lui beaucoup augmenté nous avons aussi
développé la prise en charge de l'appel
téléphonique pour un certain nombre de
patients pour faciliter la prise en
charge est donc là je pense que c'est un
levier qui trouve sa place et que nous
devons aussi conforté nous n'avions pas
de très bons chiffres en matière de télé
consultation au plan national ces
chiffres ont beaucoup augmenté et nous
devons donner une place à ce mode de
prise en charge
ça ne doit pas se substituer ni à des
consultations ya des visites à domicile
mais ça doit trouver sa place dans la
prise en charge en ambulatoire que nous
offrons à tous les patients ça c'est un
premier point après je pense malgré tout
que nous avons des progrès dans le
renforcement de la place qui pourra être
la leur dans les semaines qui viennent
si nous devons être confronté un nouveau
rebond de l'épidémie c'est très
important je ne reviens pas vous l'avez
largement évoqué ce matin nous avions
des difficultés ne faut pas le cacher
sur les équipements de protection
individuelle
ils ont aussi pesé et nous avions aussi
le confinement et des patients qui
avaient des réticences aller parfois
physiquement voir leur médecin ou leur
professionnel de santé
donc ça ce sont des choses sur
lesquelles nous devons travailler pour
nous assurer que la médecine générale
largement la médecine de premier recours
joue pleinement le rôle qui est le sien
dans la prise en charge des patients y
compris en cas de rebond épidémique et
j'ajoute un dernier point qui est la
mise en place du service d'accès aux
soins qui vise à mieux organisés sur le
territoire
la régulation médicale de la prise en
charge des soins nos programmes et
qu'elle soit effectuée par le
généraliste ou par l'établissement
c'est quelque chose qui nous manque qui
est en développement et je vois que
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de deux sas
préfigurateurs en quelque sorte sont mis
en place dans un certain nombre de
régions
pendant cette période épidémique sané je
pense pas un hasard et c'est je pense un
mode d'organisation dont nous avons
besoin et si je tire le fil où il avait
très largement évoqué ce matin
nous devons renforcer l'organisation
structurée en ville je pense au cpt s il
y en a certes encore très peu de
constituer en tant que tel mais nous
avons vu le nombre de projets très
fortement augmenté
j'ai encore en tête un chiffre d'à peu
près cinq cent soixante dix huit projets
au jour d'aujourd'hui
ça veut dire que nous avons une
augmentation considérable pendant ces
mois là c'est très important parce que
nous avons besoin que les acteurs de
ville se structure entre eux et se
structure dans leurs relations avec
l'hôpital et le médico-social et
j'ajoute un dernier point nous avons
facilité l'intervention des
professionnels libéraux dans les ehpad
pour aussi amélioré la demi-heure prise
en charge des résidents
voilà si je devais résumer ce que je
viens de dire c'est que dans notre
système de santé je pense
qu'effectivement nous devons renforcer
l'organisation et la structuration en
ville et celle de l'eau sanitaire autour
des ehpad voilà les deux points qui me
semble important
je n'oublie pas votre question sur le
dépistage je serai prudent monsieur
comme vous le savez c'est quelque chose
qui est piloté par la direction générale
de la santé
mais ce que nous avons fait pour va
renforcer les moyens de dépistage et
nous avons atteint le million en sept
jours hier c'est ma mémoire est bonne si
j'ai bien des chiffres en tête c'est
aussi parce que nous avons notablement
fait évoluer les textes sur les
modalités et les capacités de
prescription enfin pour
ne pas les prescriptions pardon de
prélèvements et des professionnels qui
peuvent le faire au cours des dernières
semaines
nous l'avons encore fait très récemment
voilà en quelques mots pour aussi
j'espère avoir répondu à vos questions
merci en tout cas poids pour la qualité
de vos réponses le constable sur les ai
pas dans le partage enfin vous
effectivement mais la question c'est que
ce constat il a été fait en fin de
longue date
je citais à dessein 2003 dire qu'il
avait été fait en 2003
la coupure entre enfin depuis la loi de
75 en gros qui commence quand commence à
dater c'est ce ce fossé qui s'est créé
entre le sanitaire et médico-social et
pointé mais dans une somme de rapports
et de travaux et notre interrogation
collective 1 mais je vous interroge
parce que vous êtes dans une position
vous avez une expertise éminente mais
notre interrogation collectif c'est
pourquoi n'avons nous pas comblés depuis
des années donc il n'est pas dans une
lecture politicienne depuis très
longtemps pourquoi n'avons nous pas
combler ces lacunes là qui nous coûte
qui nous ont quand même coûté cher très
probablement à la survenue de la crise
enfin sur le sur le dépistage
il ya quand même une question
d'organisation
c'est à dire que on voit bien que
effectivement on a dépassé nettement le
million de tests sur sept jours
effectuée on voit très bien que les
modalités font que ce n'est pas
nécessairement il n'y a pas que le
quantitatif qui compte on va passer sur
les limites du test pcr sur ses défauts
mais comme on en a pas d'autres de toute
façon ça sert à rien de d'épilogué là
dessus on prend ce qu'on a on a sauté
speisser quand on aura les tests
salivaires ou autres qu'on aura des
meilleurs sensibilité spéciste et parent
parfait mais on prend spcr il n'empêche
que quand vous avez des délais qui sont
trop longs vous finissez par rater la
période de contagiosité entre le moment
où vous prélevez va vous demander le
prélèvement vous obtenez le résultat
vous avez le résultat positif
mais s'il ya six ou sept jours qui se
sont écoulés bas
les faits pour rompre la chaîne de
transmission vous le savez est quand
même très compliquée à mettre en oeuvre
donc on est encore une fois tout de même
dans une difficulté d'organisation qu'on
a du mal à anticiper et ce n'est pas
faute d'avoir eu il a aussi les bons
concepts puisque tester tracé protéger
dire la stratégie elle elle a élaboré
depuis longtemps et à juste titre la
mise en place de différents dispositifs
pas par l'assurance maladie par les
agences régionales de santé etc y
compris d'aller au contact des
populations pour dépister bon se fait
quand même c'est fait avec retard mais
maintenant ce fait et pourtant et
pourtant les modalités ne sont pas
satisfaisantes
au jour d'aujourd'hui donc est-ce que
c'est par défaut de on va dire de
responsabilisation directement des
acteurs locaux vous avez suggéré dans un
autre domaine de plus tôt transférer la
décision aux acteurs locaux de lui faire
quitter le niveau central
est-ce que c'est par manque d'habitude à
sion on va dire d'habitude quand on fait
face à une crise pour la première fois
effectivement on n'a pas nécessairement
les réflexes moi j'aimerais vous ayez
plus loin que vous nous disiez qu'on
n'en reste pas au constat coup je crois
qu'on partage des lacunes mais plus vous
disiez comment tout ça pourrait mieux
fonctionner
la commission l'enquète madame oui je
reviens sur votre premier sujet sur les
ehpad ce que je crois c'est que pendant
l'épidémie
nous avons dû faire évoluer des
pratiques des textes aussi parce que par
exemple sur l'achat des il y avait des
restrictivement pour l'intervention
rapide de l'achat des en ehpad
nous avions aussi des questions de
moyens que nous devions régler je pense
aux équipe mobile de gériatrie donc là
c'est à nous de donner les moyens y
compris financiers pour faire
fonctionner et développer ses structures
je pense aussi aux astreintes les
astreintes il faut les financer il faut
que les professionnels qui viennent et
ça ça faisait partie des choses que nous
n'avions pas fait et donc pour l'espace
les décisions qui ont été prises c'est
que toutes ces évolutions juridiques que
nous avons mises en place pour faciliter
et et faire en sorte que dorénavant il
n'est plus comment dire
en tout cas notre objectif plus d pad
sans accroche sanitaires nous avons fait
bouger les textes et nous avons mis des
moyens financiers c'est concrètement
c'est ça que nous avons fait et donc
c'est ça que nous devons continuer de
faire pour s'assurer que cette
organisation elle persiste avec les
dispositions juridiques qui le
permettent et qui même j'ai envie de
dire l'y oblige
et ensuite les moyens financiers qui le
garantis sur le territoire ensuite nous
l'avons piloter avec les ars avec un
reporting toutes les semaines pour
vérifier que effectivement c'était bien
mis en place à et je pense que c'est ça
qui a fonctionné et c'est ça que nous
devons conserver
si je reviens au test je suis prudent
parce que c'est plutôt une conférence
compétence de la direction générale de
la santé non mais je vous le dis très
simplement ce que je vois c'est que nous
nous avons fait une priorisation et je
pense c'est ça qui est important parce
que ce qu'ont connu les laboratoires
c'est un afflux de patients très
importants qui sont venus se faire
dépister
d'autant qu'il n'y a plus de
prescription comme vous le savez ce qui
est une facilitation qui est
intéressante
donc c'est très important qu'il y ait
une priorisation possible dans la prise
en charge de ces patients et ensuite
dans les délais il me semble qu'on est
dans un délai plus court en moyenne donc
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya de la
disparité finalement en fonction des
lieux et qu'on est sur des délais plus
courts que cinq six jours et j'avais en
tête un délai moyen de 1,6 jours donc je
vérifierai pour vous le dire mais c'est
ça que j'ai à l'esprit mais ce qui veut
dire aussi qu'il ya des disparités qui
ne sont pas nécessairement satisfaisante
à charge pour nous à se donner les
moyens de renforcer nos capacités à
faire et du coup parmi les choses que
nous nous avons fait parce que c'est du
ressort de la dge est pour le coup c'est
de détendre les types de professionnels
qui peuvent faire les prélèvements pour
donner de la facilitation aux ars pour
qu'elles puissent l'organiser au plan
local
voilà ce que je peux dire en réponse à
vos questions merci vous avez tendu
jusqu'au kiné
entre nous sommes en train de le faire
oui pardon
sylvie vermeillet merci monsieur le
président je reviendrai sur trois points
madame la directrice
vous avez tout d'abord évoqué l'agilité
des ars je pense qu'en fonction des
territoires et laura était différente
cette ars cette agilité des ars et ceci
dit en fonction des territoires ils
n'ont pas été sollicités de la même
façon mais ensuite vous avez parlé des
coopération interministérielle qui ont
été très efficaces dans certains cas je
pense qu'entre le ministère de
l'intérieur et le ministère de la santé
notamment entre les préfets et les
agressent vous pouvez peut-être nous en
dire plus
en tout cas de nous au cours de la
commission on a pu constater qu'il ya eu
des dysfonctionnements en fonction des
départements et que l'efficience a été
parfois source de de dysfonctionnements
je pense qu'on peut aller jusque là mais
j'aimerais avoir votre sentiment sur sur
ce point et savoir ce que vous pensez
qu'on pourrait faire pour que pour que
les incidents qui se sont produits
pendant la crise ne se ne se reproduise
pas ensuite un autre point qui pour moi
est important et très sensible alors
contrairement à un mais deux 2 excellent
collègue rapporteur moi je ne suis pas
médecin mais je voudrais revenir sur un
point c'est la priorisation priorisation
des patients c'est quelque chose qui
pour moi ne va pas de soi comment vous
déterminez 7 cette organisation en tout
cas pendant la crise du cru comprendre
qu'il y avait bien eu une priorisation
des patients qu'aux vide qu'est ce qui
fait qu'on qu'on puisse décider qu'un
patient qu'ovide est prioritaire sur un
autre patient comment vous déterminez
qu'on puisse faire perdre des chances de
survie à d'autres malades en tout cas
plus qu'à ceux du coc vide ça c'est une
intérêt une interrogations éthiques
mais je j'ai envie de vous poser cette
question et l'autre question en matière
de priorisation à la lumière de des
auditions d'hier
est-ce qu'il était également bien prévu
que les patients des ehpad ne soit plus
admis à l'hôpital cette priorisation l'a
apparemment elle et elle est
caractérisée je voudrais que vous nous
donner des explications sur sur ces deux
priorisation et puis troisième point
vous avez parlé de la réorganisation de
la capacité de réanimation à la fois un
niveau national et régional que vous
pouviez avoir ses perspectives est ce
que c'est quelque chose de ponctuel ou
de pérenne c'est à dire que est ce que
vous allez monter en puissance la
capacité nationale de façon pérenne et
quand vous parlez d'un niveau régional
est ce que ça veut dire que à l'avenir
vous auriez une adaptabilité à un niveau
régional de façon à pouvoir répondre à
des besoins en cas d'infection plus
localisée à certains endroits merci
merci
en ce qui concerne l'agilité alors tout
n'est pas absolument parfait pour tout
le monde enfin pour que ce soit nos
plans national houppelande enfin me
semble-t-il des acteurs locaux comme
vous l'avez dit chaque ars chaque région
a été confrontés à des réalités
différentes
moi j'ai écouté avec attention ce que
nous ont dit les ars je vois qu'il ya
des positif ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
n'y a pas eu de difficultés à certains
endroits mais il me semble que allons y
compris des auditions que vous avez
effectué on a vu par exemple l'île de
france avec de très bonne coopération je
crois que c'était le cas aussi des hauts
de france pour les audi enfin donc on a
quand même on voit bien qu'on a là des
choses intéressantes et qui se sont bien
passés après moi en terme d'organisation
je pense à un autre sujet sur lequel je
m'interroge sur le fait de donner de
nous des recommandations mais je sais
que les ars y pense pour avoir échangé
avec lol
directeur de l'offre de soins récemment
c'était pour ce qui concernait la
gouvernance avec les établissements
publics et privés
moi je crois que les ars qui ont mis en
place des échanges avec les
établissements et publics et privés ont
mis en place une bonne pratique qu'il
nous faut développer
je le dis comme un exemple finalement
d'amélioration de nos pratiques au plan
collectif qui me semblent intéressants
et sur lequel les échanges que nous
avons entre nous nous permettre de
progresser dans la façon dont nous
pouvons faire face à une épidémie de ce
genre en ce qui concerne la priorisation
nous n'avons pas nous donner de consigne
de priorisation je vais développer un
petit peu parce que c'est un sujet
important nous avons si je prends la
déprogrammation
nous avons demandé de déprogrammer
toutes les activités non urgentes pour
pouvoir se concentrer sur la prise en
charge des patients qu'on vite mais j'ai
bien dit non urgentes
sachant que nous n'avons pas nous défini
quels étaient les activités urgentes qui
n'était pas du coup vite voyez ce que je
veux dire et c'est très important parce
que ça n'est pas au national de définir
qui doit être pris en charge y compris
de patients non qu'ovide pendant la
paire de l'épidémie c'est très très
important ça n'est pas le faire je vous
donne un autre exemple au moment de la
reprise d'activité je l'évoquais tout à
l'heure quand nous avons dit que
l'activité devait reprendre
nous n'avons pas fixé ni de liste de
pathologie ni de liste d'actes ce n'est
pas à nous de le faire
nous considérons que ce sont aux acteurs
locaux de le faire en fonction de l'état
de santé des patients et de la situation
des établissements et du niveau de
l'épidémie
ce n'est pas à nous de dire quels sont
les patients prioritaire nous n'avons
pas donné de consigne de priorisation et
j'y reviens c'est un sujet important
notamment pour les résidents dans les
ehpad
nous n'avons pas donné de consigne non
plus et je crois que les sociétés
savantes se sont d'ailleurs exprimé en
juillet dernier sur le point il y à des
recommandations de bonnes pratiques des
sociétés savantes sur les critères
d'admission et de prise en charge des
patients mais ce ne sont des critères de
bonne pratique des sociétés savantes
nous n'avons pas nous a donné des
recommandations de ce type là et nous ne
l'avons pas fait c'est très important
nous considérons que la prise en charge
des patients elle est fonction de leur
état de santé est pas fonction de
d'instruction qui
andrée d'une administration centrale
voilà je dis très simplement et je crois
que c'est très important et notamment
les sociétés savantes que ce soit les
sociétés savantes de réanimation et
d'urgentistes non vraiment clairement
redit au mois de mai dernier c'est très
important qu'il n'y ait pas d'ambiguïté
sur ce point je reviens à votre dernière
question sur la réorganisation des
réanimations vous connaissez les
chiffres nous avons des capacités de
réanimation de soins continus et de
soins intensifs qui sont importantes et
qui sont différents d'une région à
l'autre et pour nous la question que
nous travaillons avec les réanimateurs
c'est quel est le bon niveau de capacité
en réanimation dont nous devons disposer
au plan national et au plan régional et
ces deux questions sont également
importantes puisque en fait quand vous
regardez la carte
les régions sont dotées d'une manière
différente et la question c'est quelles
sont les critères est ce que nous devons
renforcer certaines régions plutôt que
d'autres et nous voyons bien que
certaines régions n'ont pas eu les
capacités suffisantes pour prendre en
charge leurs patients alors je pense à
des grosses régions comme grand test
comme aux trans ou l'ile-de-france mais
y compris la bourgogne franche comté qui
a pendant toute la période de l'épidémie
organisées directement des transferts
des dépôts des voeux de patients avec
auvergne rhône-alpes qui était à côté
avec des capacités plus forte
donc la question qui est devant nous et
que nous travaillons en ce moment avec
eux c'est de se dire quel est le bon
niveau est peut-être aurons-nous à
l'issue de ces discussions
une décision qui dira il faut x place en
plus en france
elles doivent être plutôt à tel endroit
qu'à tel autre je ne préjuge pas de la
fin de discussion mais c'est en tout cas
quelque chose de pérenne en tout cas
c'est une discussion qui doit aboutir à
des décisions qui seront pérennes qui
n'exclut pas le nôtre possibilité à
moyen terme de faire ce que les
professionnels ont très bien fait certes
d'étendre les capacités de prise en
charge en réanimation en ayant recours
aux unités de soins intensifs et de
soins continus qui leur ont permis que
ce que certains d'entre eux at elle de
mettre en place des réalités mer pour
prendre en charge un afflux de patients
important dans les services de soins
critiques
et un poids de précision quand même vous
nous dites que vous n'avez pas donné de
de liste d'actes dans le cas de la
reprise des activités sauf qu'il ya drs
qui ont quand même signifié semble-t-il
vous avez écouté les auditions ce matin
à des établissements que s'il respectait
pas le critère d'urgence ils pouvaient
ne pas être remboursés des actes
effectués
donc ce sont des décisions locales
ce ne sont pas des décisions nationales
j'ai écouté ce qui a été dit ce matin en
effet j'ai clairement à l'esprit ce que
vous indiquez vous confirmez je ne peux
pas qu enfin je ne confirme pas j'ai
entendu ce matin donc je ne peux pas
confirmer si ce sont des éditions
comprises les rs je ne sais pas mais je
vais le regarder en tout cas ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que ça n'était pas
la consigne nationale
en tout cas à coeur et nous avons laissé
et c'est encore et je crois que c'est
important nous avons noué nationale
laissé le soin à chaque organisme
régional chaque ars de décider de la
mise en oeuvre contenu y compris des
contraintes différentes qui pesait sur
elle parce que vous l'avez dit madame
les régions n'étaient pas toutes dans le
même état en fait n'avait pas tout la
suppression il construit en termes de
nombre de patients de capacité et puis
aussi certains n'ont évoqué ce matin de
médicaments disponibles et ça c'était
très important à certains moments de la
gestion de l'épidémie
merci catherine de roche oui merci sur
le président et merci de votre
intervention avant que les rapporteurs
pose la question en effet pas ce que
vous avez fait un blessé un portrait de
ce qui a été votre action et c'est vrai
que ce matin les fédérations salué
l'assouplissement qui a été donnée par
la dg os dans des procédures mais
néanmoins c'est vrai que dans toutes les
auditions que l'on a fait depuis le
début on sentait bien on a entendu les
acteurs du
du domicile mais aussi des ehpad et hier
les ordres professionnels que tout
n'avait pas été aussi aussi parfait que
vous avez pu laisser peut-être ou du
moins un match et je mal compris les
sens tant durant votre intervention
moi j'avais plusieurs questions vous
avez évoqué la télémédecine en dix ans
nous étions en retard c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu des prolongations de prise en
charge jusqu'au 31 décembre de certains
actes
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser
lesquelles mais si on était en retard
aussi c'était parce que on est en pleine
négociation du remboursement des actes
de télémédecine et envoyé bien que
c'était très circonscrits au départ ans
avec les négociations entre la entre la
cnam et les professionnels de santé
donc où est ce qu'on en est et est ce
que ça va être pérennisée je vous avais
fait partie de la feuille de route que
le ministre olivier ferrand a donné au
nouveau directeur de la cnam mais c'est
vrai qu'on entendait hier par exemple
les kinés qui parlait des difficultés
qu'ils ont sur les télésoins beaucoup de
points ou certes on ne leur permettaient
mahé des tarifs qui étaient peu
encourageants et qui ne correspondaient
pas aux besoins ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'était à quel
moment s'est fait la bascule entre les
consignes du départ qui était dire
n'allez surtout pas chez votre médecin
traitant appeler le 15
c'était une bassine partout qu'on avait
nous même au sénat et finalement l'idée
de dire vous pouvez aller voir votre
votre médecin à quel moment ces faits
cette bascule est ce que vous avez une
idée de la date précise et pourquoi elle
s'est faite je me souviens une début
mars et lorsqu'on a vu le débat au sénat
moi j'avais alerté le ministre vert en
effet sur ce tales risque d'engorgement
du 15
puisque on ramenait tout 15 donc à quel
moment cela s'est fait moi ce que je
voudrais savoir c'est dans cette
chronologie qu'elle était
au mois de février avant qu'arrive la
vague de vagues dans grand test puis
ensuite l'accélération des procédures
avec cesser cette épidémie qui se
déployaient dans la région de grand test
est un peu décalé en ile-de-france où
qu'ils se développer dans les hauts de
france et que cette crainte en effet que
ça arrive partout qu'elle était au mois
de février où fin janvier ou courant
février
quels étaient les réflexions la dg os
par rapport à la gestion de cette crise
ou est-ce que vous en étiez pourquoi je
vous dis ça c'est parce que quelque
chose qui me frappe c'est que le on le
grand test nous a dit tout début mars
envoyait le tsunami arrivait et en même
temps le 6 mars on incitait les français
aller au restaurant aller au cinéma et
au théâtre
très prisé dans la république il avait
dit est ce que là on était dans une
démarche de d'immunité collectif qui
n'auraient pas été dit pourquoi pas ça
ne paraisse pas une critique mais est-ce
que c'était cela comment vous expliquer
ce décalage entre ce qui se passait dans
le grand test les consignes et enfin
argument les conseils qu'ils étaient
donnés sur paris voilà les premières
questions
merci tout d'abord sur la télémédecine
alors c'est vrai que il y avait
plusieurs france et je peux dire au
développement de la télémédecine vous
l'avez évoqué il y avait d'abord la
question de la tarification et c'est la
mission que le ministre a confié au
nouveau directeur général de la cnam que
de reprendre les négociations sur ce
champ là et puis il y en a un deuxième
qui a facilité les choses
c'est aussi la prise en charge à 100%
par l'assurance maladie obligatoire et
ça ça a été une facilitation importante
et c'est quelque chose
c'est un texte que nous avons pris au
tout début et qui perdure encore
aujourd'hui et qui a beaucoup facilité
de la même manière que pendant cette
phase là le fait de rembourser la prise
en charge par téléphone et pour
certaines personnes c'est important
parce que tout le monde n'est pas à
l'aise avec la téléconsultation en tout
cas pour certains patients c'est le cas
donc voilà donc je pense qu'il ya deux
choses en miroir il ya la tarification
d'une part et puis la prise en charge à
100% qu'il a pour le coup pour le
patient est un élément de féliciter
facilitation donc ça je sais que la cnam
le discuter le négocie donc c'est en
cours et je pense que c'est un élément
important et notre notre responsabilité
maintenant c'est de préserver cette cet
outil ou cette prise en charge dans la
palette des pratiques pour l'ensemble
des professionnels qu'ils soient
médecins ou kiné ou infirmiers voilà
pour la première question
pour votre deuxième question alors c'est
vrai comme il y a eu en plusieurs phases
assez différente et ce que vous évoquez
c'est la phase 2 la phase iii en fait
c'est à dire que dans la phase 2
finalement c'était la période où
l'épidémie était très concentrée sur
quelques lieux et on était dans une
phase finalement 2 d'abord on savait
très peu de choses de la maladie en fait
de enfin je le redis parce que notre
connaissance a beaucoup progressé depuis
et ensuite notre préoccupation
collective était l' isolement le
le jeu cherche le fait de contenir de
manière très limitée et d'éviter la
propagation de freiner la propagation de
l'épidémie c'était ça la phase 2 et
c'est vrai que dans cette phase là nous
nous sommes beaucoup reposé sur le 15 et
l'activité des samu a très fortement
progressé
nous vous transmettrons les chiffres
vous les avez demandé et c'est vraiment
extrêmement intéressant de voir le pic
très important d'activités et j'avais
des relations
j'avais des échanges à ce moment-là
quotidien avec les urgentistes qui ont
fait évoluer très fortement leur
capacité à prendre en charge les appels
avec des renforts de personnel avec
aussi des organismes des organismes de
téléphonie qui les ont aidés pour
s'équiper pour adapter leur capacité à
prendre en charge ces appels dans
certains endroits ça a été vraiment
extrêmement impressionnant et ça ça a
duré pendant la période de la phase deux
serpents dans quelques jours je parle de
mémoire on pourra vous envoyer la
chronologie c'est effectivement tout
début mars et la bascule en phrases 3 a
fait baisser cette pression puisque là
on était dans une propagation de
l'épidémie où l'on savait qu'ils
seraient plus importantes en fait et du
coup c'est ça la bascule entre les deux
je pense que le directeur de la générale
de santé on parlerait mieux que moi
puisque c'est lui qui pilotait vraiment
ces différentes faces mais c'est
vraiment ça la bascule entre la phase 2
3 et c'est à ce moment là qu
effectivement cette évolution s'est fait
sentir et que la pression sur le 15
c'est beaucoup relâché avec cette
bascule là donc ça c'est vraiment ce
moment là et je pourrais vous en donner
la chronologie de manière extrêmement
précise et c'est vrai que pour nous à ce
moment là notre notre préoccupation
était de préparer l'ensemble du système
de santé au développement de l'épidémie
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas un hasard
quand vous le voyez la déprogrammation
c'est le 12 mars donc c'est à ce moment
là et la chronologie est vraiment
parlante parce que vous voyez bien que
vous avez la phase ii avec des endroits
très très identifiée comme grand test
comme l'oise et ensuite la bascule en
phase iii c'est quand on voit qu on a
une propagation et qui est concomitante
et ça n'est pas un hasard avec des
mesures très importantes notamment au
confinement qui a permis de stopper
très fortement la propagation des
épidémies et de limiter l'afflux de
personnes en réanimation et comme vous
savez le pic de prise en charge des
patients en réanimation a été atteint le
7 avril entre début mars et le 7 avril
la montée de le nombre de patients pris
en charge en réanimation a été constante
est assez impressionnante il faut le
dire je n'ai pas eu l'impression excusez
moi mais pour compléter si catherine me
permets moi j'ai pas eu l'impression que
le message avait changé de ne pas
appeler le 15 quoi à la télévision on
voyait encore les spots me semble-t-il
même après on dit d'appeler le 15
appeler le 15 non si je ne m'abuse
changé bardon du coup j'ai dû être
jamais manqué de clarté dans mes propos
bien sûr que quand la situation est
grave le message est toujours d'appeler
le 15 quand les personnes sont en forme
comment dire ou un doute sur leur état
de santé ou ont besoin de dead c'est
évident après le message était aussi de
dire si vous êtes sur une forme modérée
appelez votre médecin généraliste et
d'ailleurs pendant toute la durée de
l'épidémie vous avez eu des patients qui
ont eu qui ont été atteints par le cos
vide et qui ont eu des formes très
modérée ou modérée et qui ont été pris
en charge notamment via la
téléconsultation qu'il était une majeure
par une partie très importante de
l'activité des médecins
merci sur l'immunité collective
ça c'est plutôt je suis désolé c'est
vraiment le directeur général de la
santé qui pourrait vous répondre
on a bien l'intention de lui poser la
question
merci nous allons passer aux questions
de nos de nos commissaires j'ai cinq
demandes de parents une manière jourda
roger karoutchi victoire jasmin j'ai
très vite jean sol je vais groupe et les
trois premiers donc muriel jourda
merci messieurs président j'ai trois
questions la première a trait à propos
de madame julienne sur le des acquis de
cette crise est une des actions qui a
été de permettre aux ars de prendre des
décisions dans des délais plus courts
qu'habituellement et vous avez cités si
je ne me trompe pas notamment les
autorisations pour les lits de
réanimation
je voulais savoir quel était le délai
habituel d'autorisation et quel était le
délai qui a permis ces autorisations
pendant la période de crise et vous avez
indiqué que probablement il s'agissait
d'une piste pour l'avenir que de donner
plus d'autonomie aux ars qu'elle est
aujourd'hui l'autonomie des ars par
rapport à la direction générale de
l'offre de soins
ça c'est la première question la seconde
a trait aux propos vous avez tenus sur
la collaboration entre l'hôpital public
et les structures privées la médecine de
ville
aviez vous une vision une doctrine sur
cette collaboration et quelles ont été
les consignes données pour la mettre en
oeuvre et comment le cas échéant on
l'envisagé vous à l'avenir et enfin
toujours dans les pistes d'amélioration
je voudrais évoquer les tests au début
de la crise les laboratoires
départementaux par l'intermédiaire des
conseils départementaux et leurs
présidents ont sollicité de pouvoir
procéder à des tests
il ya je crois 75 laboratoires
départementaux en france la réponse
positive est parvenu je crois à peu près
trois semaines et demie après la demande
qui en a été fait ce qui ne paraît pas
un délai compatible avec une période de
crise qui nécessite des réponses dans
des délais rapides
vous indiquez encore aujourd'hui que
différents professionnels de santé sont
à bille
et à procéder à des tests encore
récemment donc on est passés délai de
quelques semaines un délai de plusieurs
mois pour permettre aux tests de se
faire plus facilement ce qui ne paraît
pas non plus compatibles avec une
période de crise lorsque des décisions
plus rapides ne peuvent être envisagées
comme une piste d'amélioration pour une
réponse à une crise éventuelle future
merci roger karoutchi oui ma première
question rejoint un petit peu ce que ce
que tu viens de dire muriel jourda
on nous a dit en début ou tout début de
la crise la france disposait de cinq
mille cinq cents lits de réanimation
on nous a dit plus récemment que
évidemment du fait des commandes de
respirateurs de l'ouverture du nouvel an
nous étions à peu près onze mille lits
de réanimation et on voit apparaître
maintenant une nouvelle notion qui est
assez surprenante c'est la notion de
capacité de l'animation glissante c'est
à dire combien de personnes peuvent
passer en réanimation sur un mois deux
mois puisque par définition ils y
restent pas tous deux mois et un chiffre
est sorti apparemment de la direction
générale la santé sur la capacité de la
france 2 d'avoir dix sept mille
personnes en réanimation en deux mois
est ce qu'on peut en réalité avoir un
vrai chiffre définitif clair combien y
at-il de capacités non pas avec des
respirateurs de complément mais avec des
respirateurs lourd bien équipé avec le
personnel qui va avec
est-ce que nous sommes plutôt à 10 ans
bill ou bien est-ce qu en réalité ça
n'était que une capacité très provisoire
pendant la crise et deuxième question
alors la plus globale
ce matin et d'ailleurs dans les séances
précédentes
on a à plusieurs reprises dit il ya trop
de structures je parle pas seulement les
ars mais bon comité scientifique
direction générale de la santé comité
national de la santé publique organismes
en tout genre il ya beaucoup trop de
structures
on y comprend plus grand chose
d'ailleurs et
acune défend un peu son pré carré c'est
moi qui m'occupe des masques c'est moi
qui m'occupe la répartition c'est moi
qui m'occupe de chemins creux est ce que
vous n'avez pas le sentiment que cette
crise aurait dû ou devrait permettre une
simplification des structures de
décision en matière de santé parce que
peut-être qu'en temps normal ça ne pose
pas de véritable problème mais dans des
périodes d'urgence et de crise grave
l'espèce de concurrence entre toutes ces
structures est tout à fait ravageuse
merci les toits jasmin merci beaucoup
monsieur le président oui madame la
directrice de l'offre de soins je parle
des invisibles et qui sont aussi
inaudible
il s'agit de laboratoires de biologie
médicale que ce soit dans les
établissements publics de santé mais
aussi les établissements
extrahospitalier vous avez fait votre
intervention vous n'avez pas du tout par
les laboratoires dont l'offre de soins à
ils ont un rôle essentiel dans le
diagnostic clinique et dans l'aide à la
décision
je ne comprends pas que le gouvernement
ait fait des annonces concernant un
nombre de tests à réaliser et là dans le
droitier de ce qui a été dit par ma
collègue madame jourdain avec une très
grande méconnaissance de la situation
exacte des différents laboratoires
tous les laboratoires n'étaient pas
capacitif pour le savoir de prendre en
charge les tests d'une part au début il
y avait des problèmes parce que les
tests n'étaient pas performants firme
est sensible mais après il y a également
des difficultés des équipements
rappelez-vous en fin d'année 2010 9
quasiment tous les laboratoires tous les
syndicats de biologistes étaient en
grève
alors je ne sais pas si vous savez
quelles étaient les vraies raisons
mais là peu de temps après on se rend
compte que les laboratoires sont
limitées parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
équipements nécessaires et à des
surcoûts considérables
si pour les doter et dans les annonces
du gouvernement il y a également
l'utilisation des laboratoires des
services vétérinaires du laboratoire
vétérinaire
alors que pour les mettrons à
disposition
il faut qualifier le matériel il faut
habiliter le personnel
et je trouve regrettable qu'à aucun
moment dans vos discours respectifs vous
n'ayez eu une attention particulière
pour les biologistes pour les
techniciens de laboratoire qui ont
travaillé 24 heures sur 24 pendant toute
cette période quasiment pour répondre
non seulement aux besoins liés aux coûts
vide mais à tous les autres besoins de
la santé dans les milieux hospitaliers
dans les cliniques
donc je crois à filippo qu'on revoie les
fonctionnements les dysfonctionnements
mais aussi les omissions volonté en pas
parce que les laboratoires ont besoin
d'une attention particulière et la brève
de novembre 2019 témoignent les
difficultés qu'ont les laboratoires
aujourd'hui
donc ils sont invisibles parce qu'ils
sont dans les labos ils ne sont pas là
ils ne font pas de bruit
il n'était pas seul et rond point
pourtant il ya de gros problèmes
et aujourd'hui quand on voit les files
d'attentes devant certains laboratoires
alors que vous voulez tester n'est
contestée il faut des personnes les
personnes qui sont formés des personnes
qui sont qualifiés des personnes qui
sont compétentes
il en manque certainement mais il faut
valoriser ceux qui sont déjà là et
prendre en compte les différentes
recommandations des différentes nations
notamment pour l'accréditation des
laboratoires mais aussi les besoins des
différents syndicats parce que quasiment
tous les syndicats de biologistes ont
été appelés le gouvernement avant même
qu'il y ait cette crise donc le
bourgueil que vous déjà parce que vous a
dit reprise du nouvel emplacement que
vous prenez en compte les laboratoires
mais avec les personnes qui sont dedans
parce que vous dans votre discours vous
n'avez pas parlé du tout monsieur zhang
a parlé des tests et des laboratoires
madame jouda part également des casse
mais les tests ne sont pas tout seul je
vous remercie
merci madame la directrice pour ces
trois jeunes intervenants
merci beaucoup
alors je vais les prendre dans l'ordre
en ce qui concerne les tories les
autorisations d'activité alors les
autorisations auquel je faisais allusion
en termes de d'hypothèses de transfert
aux ars sont les autorisations
d'activité exceptionnel en
qui ont servi pour la réanimation mais
pas qu'eux qui sont une procédure qui
est différent du régime des
autorisations habituelles qui répondent
à des textes que nous souhaitons
d'ailleurs simplifiée de manière dans le
droit commun de manière courante
quel que soit le secteur d'activité nous
pensons que de ce point de vue là nous
devons progresser notamment sur le
renouvellement des autorisations et
simplifier les procédures qui existent
ça fait consensus avec les fédérations
hospitalières ça fait partie des
discussions que nous avons eues dans le
cadre du ségur sur le volet
simplification et je pense que dans le
droit commun nous devons le faire c'est
cette mécanique là elle est un peu
particulière puisque on est vraiment
dans la réponse à une situation
exceptionnelle et c'est vrai que je
cours je pense que s'agissant d'une
autorisation exceptionnelle elle est
plus adapté au niveau de la rs qui est
la mieux à même de mesurer
pourquoi elle en a besoin dans quelles
conditions ils pour répondre à quels
besoins ce qui n'exclut pas une
évolution due process d'autorisation qui
est un process assez long qui éduque
idée d'une durée variable entre
l'autorisation initiale et le
renouvellement de l'autorisation et qui
répondent à des process à la fois qu'ils
sont différents en terme de contenu du
dossier et compte tenu des demandes qui
sont des demandes dire à la qualité à la
sécurité des soins et qui d'autre part
et point une procédure qui découle aussi
des prs élaboré par les ars
donc pour moi il ya deux sujets il ya
d'une part simplifier le droit commun et
ça il faut le faire au moins pour le
renouvellement c'est très important et
ensuite pour cet outil qui est répondent
à des besoins et là pour le coup qui ont
montré leur utilité pendant la gestion
de l'épidémie
transféré aux ars la capacité de
délivrer ces autorisations dont elle est
le plus à même de déterminer leur
caractère primordial c'est combien ces
des cycles en fait parce que en fait les
autorisations son corps elle est des
renouvellements de peu en fin de
programme en deux ans
le problème c'est que enfin le problème
le procès de la procédure c'est que vous
devez avoir un plan régional leur accord
qui permet à l'ol de santé exactement
exane est d'accord par rapport à la
quelques semaines même pas les
autorisations exceptionnelles en cas
d'urgence et quelques jours en fait ça
permet d'être très réactif c'est pour
une crise merci c'est ponctuel tout à
fait pas peur elle rentre pas dans
l'organisation pérenne des soins sur un
territoire mais ça répond à une demande
urgente ponctuelles en ce qui concerne
l'hôpital public et privé nous avons
toujours donné des d'abord eu des
relations avec les acteurs publics et
privés
ensemble je l'évoquais au début en
introduction nous avions des conférences
avec les fédérations hospitalières
tous les deux jours pendant toute la
gestion de l'épidémie et c'était toutes
les fédérations en même temps donc elle
était au même niveau d'information et
c'était très important qu'on ait ces
échanges
ensemble vous les avez vu tout ce matin
c'était la même chose pour nous et dont
les recommandations que nous diffusions
nous ne faisons pas de différence et
nous demandions à ce que l'organisation
se fasse avec les secteurs public et
privé
et si vous regardez d'ailleurs la
recommandation de tout début mai que
j'évoquais sur la reprise activités nous
demandions explicitement à ce que
l'ensemble des acteurs du territoire
soit pris en compte et à ce que la
reprise d'activité prenne en compte à la
fois les secteurs public et privé
c'est très important en terme de
recommandation vous me direz quel est le
type de recommandations que nous
pourrions donner moi j'ai évoqué mais je
sais que les ars le font beaucoup
déjà le fait de mettre en place une
gouvernance de manière généralisée et
incertain de la grèce notamment ile de
france ou de france que vous avez
auditionné avait mis en place des
échanges réguliers voire quotidiens avec
les établissements publics et privés
ça nous semble être une bonne pratique
et nous pensons que c'est quelque chose
que nous pourrions recommandé mais très
honnêtement je pense que la plupart des
ars sont dans l'idée de le faire et je
sais que l'une d'entre elle la fait
encore très récemment
ça c'était pour la coopération public
privé
pardon
tout à fait tout à fait parce
qu'effectivement à leur médecine de
ville c'est vrai à la fois avec les
huées repaissent notamment avec lesquels
c'est vrai que moi je n'ai pas de
difficulté à le recommander c'est très
important et je ne fasse tous les dg drs
avec qui j'en ai parlé nous ont dit le
faire moi je pense que ça n'aurait que
des avantages que de leurs commandes et
je pense que c'est très important parce
que vous avez raison nous devons
travailler avec l'ensemble des acteurs
et y compris la médecine de ville et
nous avons eu au plan national des liens
réguliers avec la médecine de ville
c'est très important que ce soit les
médecins les infirmiers les kinés c'est
extrêmement important
j'essaie de reprendre les questions à
wil et les tests je vais reprendre
l'ensemble des questions sur les délais
de test alors c'est vrai que si nous
pouvons améliorer les délais je ne
verrais que des avantages à essayer de
le faire je crois que nous essayons de
faire un point très régulièrement avec
les laboratoires et et pardon si j'ai
donné le sentiment de négliger le rôle
des laboratoires tel n'était pas mon
intention
à la fois des laboratoires en ville et y
compris des hospitaliers ils jouent un
rôle fondamental à tous les moments et a
fortiori en ce moment enfin je tiens à
le dire très simplement
si j'ai donné cette impression jeunes ce
n'est pas le cas si je suis prudente sur
cette stratégie c'est parce qu'elle est
piloté par un autre directeur et que je
reste prudente s'agissant d'une
compétence qui lui échoit tout
particulièrement mais leur rôle est
évidemment fondamental
nous avons fait évoluer un certain
nombre de textes pour faciliter les
capacités à prélever nous savons il fait
finalement que il faut améliorer leurs
capacités en général et nous avons pour
cela toutes les enfants la cellule tests
pilotés par le directeur général de la
santé pour être précise à des réunions
toutes les semaines avec les
représentants des syndicats de
biologistes pour faire un point sur les
difficultés qu'ils peuvent rencontrer
quelle que soit la nature de leurs
difficultés y compris celles que vous
évoquez il me reste à portée sur les
agréments le délai désagréments
pour les labos vétérinaire ou pour
l'autre mais qui n'est toujours pas fait
pourquoi vous n'augmentez pas être
prenez pas rapidement les décisions pour
former très rapidement ce personnel à
faire le prélèvement nasal ça pour le
prélèvement pour les professionnels nous
avons pris plusieurs arrêtés pour
étendre le nombre de professionnels qui
avec des formations qui sont assez
courtes ont la capacité de faire ces
prélèvements étaient très longs ça c'est
le premier en winner trois semaines ça
peut être plus rapide mais il nous
semble maintenant non mais je pense que
tout toutes les pistes sont bonnes à
prendre et si nous devons regarder sur
les délais d'agrément de la même manière
que nous l'avons fait sur les
autorisations
c'est quelque chose que nous pouvons
regarder moi je pense que ça fait partie
des choses que nous pouvons regarder
c'est important excusez moi mais je me
passionne mais quand vous nous dites un
million de tests c'est pas ce qui nous
intéresse et les tests réalisés
c'est comme les masques on nous dit on 1
milliard de tests commandés très bien
milliards de masses comment dénouer ce
qui nous intéresse et masques arriver
c'est pour les masques commandés
voyez sur le terrain c'est ça qui
remonte parce que quand ils arrivent pas
vous pouvez toujours en commande et donc
ce qui est important c'est la capacité
aujourd'hui des acteurs avec le nombre
de réactifs d'acteurs de la bo de
réaliser un million t c'est pas de
commander est ce qu'il ya un million de
tests par semaine actuellement lorsque
l'on a on est obligé de prioriser tout
ce qu'ils demandent ils mangeaient des
délais on a les réponses trois quatre
jours après les gens ils sont pas isolés
donc on perd son temps quoi d'accord
donc c'est ça qu'elle est l'optimisation
que vous recherchez pour améliorer le
dispositif
nous avons bien atteint 1 million de
tests hier réalisé réaliser nous avons
beaucoup augmenté nos capacités s'est
réalisé par don si j'ai été comme on
dira suffisamment clair mais c'est
réaliser réaliser mais quel est le délai
de résultats on a beau remonter le nom
de préleveurs si je puis dire on va dire
les kinés vont faire un bon une fois que
c'est fait il faut quand même analyser
et là quelle est la capacité actuelle d'
analyse et quels sont les délais donnés
par les laboratoires pour donner le
résultat parce que si vous avez été
prélevés certes si vous intéressé de
voir le résultat et de la voir le plus
rapidement possible on a des exigences
pour ceux qui voyagent et des exigences
pour le travail et puis surtout pour
pour après semaine en isolement
il ne pas contaminer l'entourage c'est
là est-ce que vous avez des notions de
délai actuel le délai moyen et j'insiste
c'est une moyenne est de 1,6 jours c'est
le délai moyen c'est parce que nous
avons que me remonter un clairement un
dos que c'est un délit moins bien merci
effectivement très bien donc on vous le
rappelle il ya peut-être des choses à
faire pardonner notre impertinence mais
le but de la commission denquête c'est
aussi et d'avancer si jamais il y avait
en prison il y avait une question sur
les chiffres en matière de réanimation
et c'est vrai que si vous reprenez les
chiffres initiaux alors il ya plusieurs
notions qui sont différentes vous avez
raison de le souligner la première
notion c'est le nombre de capacités en
réanimation
la capacité initiale alors je parle
exclusivement des lits adultes était
d'un peu plus de 5000 lits vous pouviez
ajouter des capacités en soins continus
d'un peu plus de sept mille lits et de
soins intensifs d'un peu plus de cinq
milles 8 à peu près de 5800 ligue ça
c'est en nos capacités en matière de
soins critiques stricto sensu les
capacités en réanimation était d'un peu
plus de 5000 lits l'objectif a été de
réarmer ou d'armes et respirateurs et en
professionnel et de transformer des lits
de soins continus ou de soin tests
intensifs en capacité de réanimation
c'est ce que nous avons enfin c'est que
certains professionnels appellent l'erea
éphémère et c'est comme ça que nous
avons pu étendre nos capacités de prise
en charge de patients en réanimation
ce qui n'exclut pas la question que nous
évoquions tout à l'heure qui était de
dire quel est le bon niveau de
capacitaire j'ai envie de dire en temps
normal c'est à dire est-ce que 5000
c'est suffisant ou pas qui est une
question qui est devant nous mais en
tout état de cause que nous savons c'est
que nous avons la capacité de réarmer
delhi pour étendre les capacités de
réanimation pour atteindre des capacités
très au delà des 5000 et au pic de la
crise
nous avons pris en charge en réanimation
7000 patients de mémoire c'était aux
alentours du 12 avril c'est ma mémoire
est bonne voilà ça c'est très important
pour anticiper une éventuelle besoin de
prise en charge de patients
supplémentaires en étendant ses
capacités ce qui est différent du nombre
de patients que nous pouvons prendre en
charge en même temps qui est un sujet
que nous regardons de très près puisque
vos capacités en termes de nombre de
patients pris en charge
elles dépendent aussi de la durée
moyenne de séjour de ses patients
et comme vous l'avez vu au début la
durée moyenne de séjour pouvait être
très variable et avec des durées qui
pouvait être assez longue ce qui a un
impact sur la prise en charge en
réanimation mais aussi en soins de suite
et de réadaptation
on en a peu parlé mais dans la filière
de prise en charge c'était très
important puisqu'un certain nombre de
patients après avoir passé des temps
parfois importants en réanimation avait
besoin d'une réadaptation derrière
parfois très importantes
et là aussi c'est un segment de l'offre
de soins qui a été qui a joué un rôle
très important et sur lequel nous sommes
très vigilants dans toute la filière de
prise en charge c'est ça c'est la réac
ce sont les rails sa mère c'est
exactement ça en fait tout à fait ça et
la différence avec l'allemagne en nombre
de lits par habitant alors en fait c'est
d'ailleurs ça fait partie des points que
nous avons discuté avec les cnp de
ranimation en juillet dernier nous nous
interrogeons sur la comparabilité parce
que si on compare alors de mémoire
c'était 28 mille lits en allemagne qui
était avancée si on les combat doit nous
devons nous les comparer aux 5000 lits
de réanimation ou aux 5000 lits de
réanimation plus les soins continus si
vous additionnez les deux on est déjà à
18000 à peu près je le dis parce que du
coup il faut être prêt cautionné avec
les chiffres et ça fait partie des
choses que nous investiguons mais la
question de fond qui est celle qui nous
est posée c'est quel est le niveau de
capacité de prise en charge en soins
critiques que nous devons assurer à nos
concitoyens au plan national et en
termes de répartition régionale et c'est
ça que nous travaillons en ce moment et
je pense que c'est ça qui est important
dernière question la question de
l'organisation au plan national
est ce que nous devons simplifier nos
organisations il ya des questions qui se
posent et c'est vrai que nous avons
modifié notre organisation et notre
fonctionnement pendant toute la période
de la gestion de crise puisque la
direction générale de la santé
piloter l'ensemble des dispositions
sanitaires de la crise et réunifiée sous
son égide
l'action de la direction générale de
l'offre de soins mais aussi de la
direction générale de la de la cohésion
sociale ou encore la direction de la
sécurité sociale et nous avions tous les
jours des points quotidiens avec la
direction générale de la santé et
l'ensemble des directions pour veiller à
ce qu'il y ait une bonne articulation et
je l'évoquais nous avons dû nous
réorganiser pour monter des cellules
spécifiques que ce soit en matière de
logistique pour les équipements de
protection individuelle ou bien en
matière de tests comme vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure qui comportait des
agents venant de différentes directions
pour venir en renfort et pour ses
missions très spécifique ça c'est très
important
est ce que cela veut dire que nous
devons nous réorganiser de manière plus
fondamentale
la question peut se poser en tout cas
c'est vrai que les réorganisations que
nous avons dû faire très rapidement pour
être en capacité de répondre aux
difficultés que nous poser cette crise
et pour y répondre a montré que nous
devions faire évoluer nos organisations
et parfois fusionner des équipes qui
traitent de sujets parfois proches
parfois de manière comment dire ses
concédants temps je pense à la recherche
par exemple pour avoir des équipes qui
travaillaient en commun merci deuxième
salve de questions
angèle préville gentil monsieur le
président alors moi je vais revenir sur
quelque chose qui ne s'est pas
spécialement bien passé lors de cette
crise c'est la situation et le nombre de
décès
des personnes âgées qui constituent
quasiment la moitié des décès dont la
grande majorité dans les établissements
pour personnes âgées les personnes âgées
dans ces établissements ont été mis à
l'isolément
mais il n'y avait pas les les
équipements de protection pour les
salariés qui entraient et sortaient de
ces établissements ils ont donc été
contaminés évidemment pas de façon
volontaire mais parce qu'on n'avait pas
su bien identifié que la contamination
venait par là alors que c'était évident
est donc cet isolement qui a été quand
même bien respecté n'a pas protégé
est ce que ça aurait été à votre sens
pire si on ne l'avait pas fait
moi j'ai un exemple je suis dans un
département qui a été très peu touché
par le virus de lot et les quatre
structures de ma commune et dans les
communes voisines de moitié des
résidants ont été testés positifs avec
quelques décès malheureusement donc
quels enseignements en tire de tout cela
est ce que puisqu'on avait déjà connu la
canicule
est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas un moyen de
s'inquiéter quand même quand on a ce
genre de crise et faire en sorte que au
niveau national on est une consigne
claire sur la communication et notamment
une consigne claire sur tous les
salariés qui entrent et qui sortent de
ces établissements parce que isolé c'est
bien mais si on ne teste pas ou si on ne
fait pas en sorte qu'ils aient tous les
équipements de protection
à quoi cela sert-il est-ce qu'on tire
des enseignements de ce qui s'est passé
là et de ce qui est à mon sens assez
grave à l'argent merci jean sol oui
monsieur le président pourrait vous
madame nous quantifier
et est qualifié les personnels mobilisés
en renfort tout particulièrement dans le
cadre de cette crise sanitaire sans
précédent
si possible par catégorie
socioprofessionnelle par territoire et
bien évidemment il faudrait cours et
laissé indicateurs me semble-t-il
honneur au nombre de patients traités
par le cos vite et aux pays commandez et
surtout utilisé ma deuxième question
concerne le nombre de personnels
contaminés est décédé là aussi par
catégorie socioprofessionnelle si
possible et pas par territoire qu'il
s'agisse bien évidemment de deux
titulaires ou deux renforts apportés
je vous remercie excusez moi oui
qu'est-il prévu en matière de
reconnaissance de maladie
professionnelle de ses personnels
touchés et que van advenir si vous
voulez les personnels qui sont venus en
renfort et qui donc un n'avait pas un
statut de titulaire ou de contractuels
notamment
merci je rajouterais une dernière
question si vous permettez madame la
directrice est ce que vous avez organisé
un retour d'expérience sur chaque
département pour pouvoir tenir compte de
la crise et fluidifier le parcours des
liens complémentaire des uns par rapport
aux autres pour se préparer une nouvelle
échéance éventuelles allez-y mme dumas
alors pour ce qui concerne d'abord la
question sur les ehpad alors là je serai
prudente s'agit sont aussi de quelque
chose que qui est dont la direction
générale de la cohésion sociale à la
charge et que vous avez je crois
auditionné hier
d'ailleurs c'est vrai que c'est
important d'avoir une stratégie de
dépistage des établissements sociaux et
médico sociaux qu'ils soient mises en
place et qui soit claire et y compris de
pouvoir recenser les personnels qui
reviennent par exemple de vacances et
pour lesquels des dépistages sont
importants pour les protéger eux et
protéger les résidents et est d'ailleurs
cette stratégie elle est importante au
sein des établissements de santé aussi
si vous me permettez de d'élargir
le sujet puisque en fait nous devons
aussi veiller à ce que les
professionnels puissent bénéficier de
dépistage et je sais que pour en avoir
discuté avec ses stratégies se mettent
en place dans les établissements qu'ils
soient déchus ou des ch et c'est très
important pour l'adapter en fonction de
l'état de santé des professionnels et
aussi de des services dans lesquels du
travail donc on a là des modalités qui
sont mises en oeuvre par les
établissements et qui sont extrêmement
importants ce qui fait le lien avec
l'autre question qui a été posée sur les
professionnels contaminés alors je
pourrais vous transmettre les chiffres
de santé publique france puisqu'en fait
il t'avait des chiffres entre le 1er
mars et le 21 juin 2020 qui montraient
qu'il y avait un peu plus de 30 mille
professionnels qui avaient été
contaminés et avec 84% professionnels de
santé 10 % de non soignants 29%
d'infirmiers mais je vous transmettrai
les chiffres je crois que ce sera plus
simple qui permette d'avoir un point à
date est à la fois le nombre de
personnes contaminées de personnes
décédées s'agissant des soignants mais
aussi par région comme ça a été demandé
je voulais transmettre aide de manière
précise je crois que c'est important en
ce qui concerne la reconnaissance pour
maladie professionnelle ça c'est la
direction de sécurité sociale qui
travaillent sur ce point c'est un point
important
je sais que des discussions étaient
encore en cours fin juillet qu'elle se
poursuive nous pourrions vous
transmettre les éléments que la dss
pourrez vous communiquer pour s'agissant
de l'état de ces d'avancement de ses
travaux qui sont très importants pour
les professionnels de manière générale
quel que soit leur statut
par ailleurs s'agissant des renforts
nous vous transmettrons les chiffres je
les ai pas immédiatement que ce soit par
catégorie ou par territoire ce qui
m'amène à une questions qui étaient
importantes que l'on a évoqué par
moments finalement nous cette crise nous
a permis de voir que nous devions aussi
faire évoluer la réserve sanitaire et la
façon dont nous organisions les renforts
parmi les points de recommandations que
que vous évoquez il me semble c'est un
point important puisque on voit bien que
la réserve sanitaire avaient été
initialement mise en place pour des
crises limitée dans le temps et dans
l'espace si vous me passez l'expression
et que là nous avons été face à une
crise qui a nécessité d'organiser de
manière territoriales
des renforts de professionnels
s'agissant de professionnels d'ailleurs
d'établissements publics comme privés
vers d'autres établissements soit sur un
même territoire
organisé par une ars ou soit vers
d'autres territoires
votre région et ça a été un mouvement
extrêmement important et très massif on
vous donnera les chiffres en tout cas ce
sont des chiffres qui sont éloquents
s'agissant des mouvements de ces
professionnels et là nous avons mis en
place une plateforme nationale qui
dorénavant facilitent ces renforts que
ce soit dans le sanitaire ou dans le
médico-social et c'est ainsi d'ailleurs
très important donc nous vous
communiquerons les chiffres vous évoquez
monsieur le président la question des
rites axe alors c'est vrai que au niveau
de la dg os nous l'avons fait au plan
national avec nos interlocuteurs
nationaux que ce soit des sociétés
savantes ou bien des représentants
syndicaux ou de professionnels nous ne
l'avons pas organisé par département
s'agissant de sujets de vous je pense
que les ars doivent leur garde et
puisque vous l'avez évoqué les uns et
les autres il me semble extrêmement
important de d'avoir ce retour rapide
finalement s'en aller méthodologiquement
dans ce que donnerait un vrai texte en
tant que tel mais comment nous ayons
très vite des échanges pour capitaliser
sur ce que nous avons fait d'intéressant
et ce que nous devons faire évoluer je
ne reviens pas sur des différents points
que nous avons évoqué ensemble je crois
que c'est fondamental puisque les
chiffres de propagation de l'épidémie
actuelle nous conduisent à mettre en
place l'ensemble des évolutions qui sont
indispensables pour faire face à cette
épidémie
merci et vous comptez augmenter les
capacités de traçage là compte tenu des
nombre de clusters qui augmente de façon
exponentielle n'avait pas peur d'être
saturé en ce qui concerne les capacités
de traçage que la cpam troisième degré
avec les ars non c'est vrai que c'est
une charge très lourde qui peut jouer
les ars parce que nous avons beaucoup de
clusters qui augmente ça fait partie des
sujets que nous travaillons avec elle
parce que a fortiori d'ailleurs nous
avions des clusters qui dont le nombre
de cas contacts a beaucoup augmenté
s'agissant notamment de jeunes qui
auront une vie sociale très importante
avec des cas contacts qui sont parfois
très élevés donc c'est vrai que ça fait
partie des points que nous sommes en
train de travailler pour regarder
comment améliorer et aider les ars pour
faire face à cet afflux
quand je dis les ars mais ça concerne
aussi les sais pas mais la cnam qui
marque ici
bien sûr de ce niveau là et là je crois
que c'est quelque chose sur lesquels
nous travaillons parce que c'est une
charge très très importante le
débordement risquerait de venir de là
non pas du système hospitalier
conjoncture actuelle s'il n'y a pas
d'autres questions merci en tout cas
d'avoir eu si pardon excusez moi et
voilà pour cette audition de la
commission d' enquête du sénat sur la
gestion de la crise de lakovic 19 et sur
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
pour faire face aux pandémies
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi vous pouvez revoir tous
nos programmes sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée
sur public sénat